before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
I don't know some sort of
Stone pun I guess
yeah no I couldn't really think of an
opening for this one so take two Doctor
Who reviews continue and it's time for
Village of the Angels
which I did not really like
uh on first viewing and I took a lot of
heat for that at the time like I was
taking some heat anyway people calling
me excessively negative just because I
didn't like the first episode and while
I did not Proclaim even at that time
this whole thing is definitely going to
be bad I did express my concerns and
they were brought up again with Once
Upon time but everyone else at the time
seemed really enthralled with the
village of the angels and I was not my
basic assessment at the time and in my
memory was that it started out pretty
solid but then once it had to integrate
into the overall plot of the rest of
flux it
really kind of fell apart in the back
end didn't really complete the story it
was telling because it had to just all
end in the doctor being captured and it
really felt like it was supposed to have
its own ending possibly much more tied
into the girl Peggy and you know the the
time Loop that she was in that felt like
that was supposed to be the original
thrust of the narrative
but it's it's just a thing that's kind
of there that feels very vestigial
because we have to include all the flux
stuff and we have to set up for the next
episode
that having been said
like with the previous episode on this
re-watch I did come in going okay
I already know what I don't like about
it
let's focus in and find the stuff that
works accepting that this thing is not
gonna all come together in the end like
you were unsure about what also kind of
Desperately hoping but losing that hope
rapidly on your first year and you know
it doesn't come together find the good
in this
and like once upon time there is good
here
legit good
more of it than was in Once Upon Time
although there's definitely still some
issues uh as well to be sure even aside
from
the issues that come in when flux takes
over the tail end including the climax
and the cliffhanger
so
um yeah it doesn't fully come together
but my assessment overall is better than
it was but probably still worse than
most people's I think is fair to say
although I don't know if opinion on this
episode has gone down in the wake of you
know flux finishing and realizing boy
that really wasn't going anywhere maybe
it has I don't know I definitely know at
the time I felt like a big outlier
saying it wasn't good
but anyways the cold open is real solid
the whole thing with Claire being hooked
up to the uh to the stress test and the
lie detector and just the overall
atmosphere of the thing there's real
good solid tension in that cold open and
also this episode we get Professor
Jericho who I love
I love this guy first of all the
performance is great he has a wonderful
person he has a warm
um but strong press like he's a tough
old nut this guy and I love him and part
of how I really really love him is that
at the start
I was so afraid that he was going to be
a Trope that I cannot stand
which is the snooty straw man scientist
the one who's like oh oh well it can't
be what you say it is because science
hasn't verified that which you know
that's not how science works that's
straw man science at actual scientists
would be going okay this is new because
you know what new stuff's happening all
the time but the thing is not only is he
not that given that this is a period
he's set in the freaking 60s he could
have also been massively misogynistic on
top of that would have fit the period
but he's not
he is questioning definitely at the
start like oh don't be ridiculous
Professor I have many things but I'm not
ridiculous but once it's clear what is
going on he's here he's in he's prepared
to stand up to these freaking angels
if you think of you
destroy my equity
love him
so much the doctor's gonna try and go
into Claire's mind and he's like wait
let me get through your equipment on you
first so I can record this he's like we
are we might all be about to die but for
the love of God let me at least try to
get something out of this I love him I
love him so much and he's like I'll like
him later as well when he reappears but
I love his introduction in this he's
such a good character like he's honestly
the kind of character that I can think
to myself he would have made a
legitimately good companion like for a
whole series he's great
so that is awesome overall a lot of the
tension with the angels is quite well
handled the priest counting the graves
and you know the the markers and
Counting one more than he expects
because there's an angel statue in here
he doesn't remember seeing before
there's also some interesting
would like the whole town Vanishing
thing and like the whole thing's been
taken out of time and space in in a way
they're not fully fleshed out but
they're not so unrefined that it's like
well that doesn't work at all it's more
like boy there you could have done more
with that but it's not fully detrimental
on its own
I'm not sure the Angels really benefit
in this story at least in particular
from being scaled up uh in terms of how
many of them there are or at least not
as early as it happens because
like say The Siege on the house when
it's Jericho Claire and the doctor I
think
three max would have been fine I don't
think having like
a dozen or so breaking into various
parts of the house really does much to
to up the stakes of it but there are
some moments where more of them dud like
when there's the arms coming out of the
walls in the tunnel like that's solid
and at the very end I'll give you that
like to make everything seem hopeless
there you can have a sheer High number
of them but I feel like they scaled it
up a little too early and I think the
tension actually largely works better
when there's fewer of them than when
there's more of them
tension was not as much a specific
um goal with something like say uh
Angels Take Manhattan or even really the
uh the two-parter from series five in
like in some ways but that one was
actually mostly leaning on tension with
the new things we were learning about
the angels in that one you know the
image of an Angel is also an angel the
whole thing that angel Bob did Etc
whereas this like it doesn't really add
too much that's new it just kind of
brings in a lot more of them and I'm not
sure that helped and I think it kind of
hurt the the escalation because you
could you could have gone in with the
thinking like there's like three or four
of these things and then at the very end
realize oh crap they scaled it up a
little too fast I spent more time
talking about that than I meant too
sorry about that
um so I do want to come back to Claire
so there's one really clever thing they
do with Claire but also there's a thing
that retroactively now really doesn't
work with Claire
um I'll deal with that one first so that
I can go back to being positive so the
way Claire showed up in the first
episode of this in Halloween apocalypse
she runs up to the doctor
and the whole nature of that interaction
reads much more like she knows this
because of time travel Shenanigans have
we met not yet but we will
in the past it's like her recognizing
the doctor has to do with out of sync
Time stuff
but in this episode we find out that's
not the case she got sporadic Vision
single images and she even says flat out
in this episode it didn't make any sense
well that doesn't track with how you
behaved when you tried to track down and
talk to the doctor in the first episode
you weren't acting like none of this
made sense you're acting like you
understood so having gone back to check
this it's a little better than I'm
presenting it here because there is a
quick line from Claire that kind of
brings a little bit of Doubt into her
when she first meets the doctor I think
if it's true and then in this episode
she kind of implies that for some reason
seeing the doctor in person like Snapped
everything into place and then I saw you
I'm still gonna argue that doesn't
completely track partly because how does
seeing one person mean that everything
makes sense like maybe that confirms
that what you were seeing actually meant
something and was real but that
shouldn't make you suddenly understand
what all of it meant if it was all
random and sporadic before
um numbers a year a voice telling me not
to Blink and the name of this Village it
didn't make any sense but much more
importantly these are tiny single
sentences acknowledgments of kind of the
wildliness of what's going on but what
you remember a lot more than just those
specific words is the way that they are
delivered in the way they're presented
and they're presented confidently in
Halloween apocalypse and that does not
track with what she says later about how
unsure she was in this episode so I
still think it's a problem it's just not
as much of an unaddressed one as I
presented it here that having been said
using the premonition thing
and the idea that she just had a
premonition a vision
of an Angel she's she had not other
prior to the one that sent her back in
time she had not actually encountered
them she didn't know what they were but
she had a premonition
an image in her head
and it took root and there's an angel
hiding out the whole idea of the Rogue
angel
that's a good idea too it's another
thing it's a little bit underexplored
but not so much that it like ruins it
but like I wish there had been more time
for that like why is it running
why does it want to break away why do
they want it back and we get a little
bit about that like it has to do with
information about division as to why
they want this Angel back but exactly
why it's fleeing is not really fully
gotten into but as a general premise and
a concept solid
solid I like that idea a lot and it also
um gives us a means into the final
Climax and the twists of the doctor
being turned over to the angel well
turned over to division by being given
to the angels and uh dealing with what
otherwise would have been that's a
really convoluted plan to try and catch
the doctor because if this had been the
mass group of angels planned to capture
the doctor boy that's convoluted as hell
boy was that way more complicated than
it needed to be but it's not that
it's the machinations of an angel trying
to work in a limited capacity so that it
doesn't give itself away and gets
spotted it's tracking down the doctor so
it can trade her now I'm not exactly
sure why the other Angels would honor
the Rogue Angels deal and actually I
think that gets brought up later
in a later episode like is an offhanded
line I don't know I'll have to watch for
it but like that's a little odd that it
would actually think they'd honor that
deal but as far as
the situation that the Rogue Angel was
in like yeah it's gonna have to do
something a little bit more manipulative
a little bit more convoluted because it
can't be straightforward like that
actually works and that the mass group
of angels weren't even there for the
doctor but the doctor doctor gets turned
over to them okay
that is a pretty good way to avoid the
over elaborate trap thing that it looked
like it was going to be otherwise
that having been said
there are some things that just flat out
don't work
revolves around Peggy the little girl
and also the older woman
as I said this really feels like
something that was meant to be the heart
of the episode you know at some earlier
drafting when it didn't have to carry so
much of the actual flux narrative but
then for the various reasons that the
series got reworked
it now has to deal with that and it's
still there but
not really for any reason
this twist that this older woman is
Young Peggy is meaningless
we don't know this old this old woman
has had like two scenes
and Peggy is well Peggy's a child actor
we don't get a lot from her and we don't
get a lot of sense of her I don't mean
to completely slam child actors but most
of them are very limited in their acting
ability that's just the nature of
working with a child and there are ways
to make that land better but you need to
take the time to do it and they don't so
that twist in of itself has no meaning
whatsoever and it also leads to a moment
that really ticked me off at the time
and still annoys me I actually possibly
annoys me a little bit more because it
continues to be reflective of chibnol's
issue with casual cruelty
and failure to acknowledge deaths
properly
because you have this older couple I
guess great aunt and uncle of payee who
are taking care of her and they're
looking for her and the guy is clearly a
jackass that is made clear repeatedly
and he's a jackass talking about Peggy
he's a jackass to Yaz he's a jackass to
his wife like this dude not great does
he deserve to die not I yeah I don't
know about that but he he's not somebody
I feel super bad for I'll go with that
the thing is though when he dies his
wife dies too
his wife who it looked like might have
been framed us also to some degree a
victim of his abuse
because she tried to stand up to him
earlier and he just went you can't talk
to me that way would it kill you to say
one Pleasant thing to her what do you
think gives you the right to speak to me
like that June and the response when
both of them die is for this little girl
to go it was never nice to me okay
what about her though
she died too and not a single character
nor anything about the narrative
acknowledges that fact
so why is she there
because if you're just gonna have the
jackass be the only one whose death is
acknowledged have him be the only one
who gets sent back to that later time
and then the only one who subsequently
dies
why did you kill her too
she didn't do anything
that was indicated
nothing that would make it in any way
fair or make sense for her death to go
100 unacknowledged by the child she was
helping raise
she sees two people die and goes he was
never nice to me
nothing
that
that really is my big running uh issue
with like there's a lot of problems I've
had with juveniles run the cruelty
and the inexplicable lack of an
acknowledgment of character death
because if you're not gonna have that
death mean anything
why did you bother to characterize her
why is she here if you're gonna act like
she didn't matter
like nobody cares and not even explain
why nobody cares
that I like that that stuff really rubs
me the wrong way and chimney did it
quite a bit
uh or variants of something like that
quite a bit so not happy to see it here
oh and one other thing about the death
of these characters that doesn't make
sense the premise of this is that nobody
survives getting sent back twice that's
new because the whole premise of Angels
Take Manhattan was that they were
sending people back over and over and
over and over and over and over again it
didn't come up there so why now this
doesn't bother me quite as much as it
might bug other people just because I
give a little bit of leeway for creators
not being 100 beholden to the exact
nature of things from a writer who came
before them but it like it's still not
great made a little bit worse by the
fact that the angels are being dealt
with in some of their deeper mythology
and things that they could do after
their initial introduction like the
image of an Angel is an angel thing so
you're taking some of the later editions
and ignoring others just so you can
facilitate killing these characters that
it wasn't necessarily to kill in the
first place why I don't know so while I
really don't like that and I feel the
ending is kind of weak because it
doesn't really serve as a proper climax
to this story and instead has to just
lead into a story that I don't think
work works and doesn't really go
anywhere and that does unfortunately
take the wind out of the sales of this
thing
prior to when things go off the rail
yeah it's pretty solid
I still think it's one of the weaker
Angel stories but
even a weak Angel story is still a
decent story most of the time and this
is and there are legitimate highlights
the tension in the opening Professor
Jericho just overall in general I
haven't really talked about the Dr
Yasmin and Dan but they're they're just
kind of running around doing their
standard thing for the most part and
it's solid and it works
there's some good stuff here for sure
there's also some of chiminal stuff that
absolutely drives me off the wall and I
can't stand and it ticks me off
and there's just the overall hampering
of the having to tie in the main overall
flux story
but
setting my frustration about that as
part of the side as I can
what's left is
pretty good
I get why people liked it
I don't know why people said it was like
the best of the last of this in the
previous two series because
it's it's not even minus the flux uh
connection issues it it's not but it's
solid it's pretty good
yeah
so yeah that's my opinion raised
certainly nowhere near what people were
telling me it was back when it aired but
yeah that'll do
Village of the Angels Have you ever
watched it what'd you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it patreon pays the bills and
enables me to do this as my living
there's also links to other stuff in the
description that I do
um or that I have available like merch
books blah blah blah blah blah blah
don't worry too much about that though
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
the poodle Robin Powell Tracy scrabot
angry Casper Adam RDL Taylor David Hall
Shayla gourlay and Rosalind Bennett
thanks for your support you can get your
name in the credits too if you feel like
hearing me possibly struggle with it for
several times before getting it right
[Music]
no no